charge up your time machines and give
your grandmother a foot rub because we
have a movie that doesn't have an ending
explain to me what's going on yes today
we'll be looking at see you yesterday
today will be oh you get what I mean
so strap in because here we go set in
June 2019 see you yesterday is the story
of a young genius
CJ Walker who creates a time-traveling
machine to stop the murder of her
brother Calvin but like many
time-traveling movies things don't go
according to plan starting on June 27th
2019 we get our first glimpse of CJ and
Sebastian working on their TRP machines
temporal relocation packs they work by
breaking down their molecular structure
allowing them to travel through a
wormhole and reappear in the desired
time the use of wormholes here is
especially interesting since CJ reads
Stephen Hawking's a brief history of
time which includes discussions of
wormholes time travel and multiple
timelines the only problem is that these
packs only have enough power to send
them back one day in the past that and
their first attempt is a total failure
at first we get a brief cameo from
Michael J Fox who is in some super small
indie film called Back to the Future
he's reading kindred a story about an
african-american woman who time travels
back to a pre Civil War Maryland
plantation where she meets her ancestors
Michael whose character is mr. Lockhart
posits the main question of this film if
you had that kind of power
time-traveling what would you do what
would you change it's this question that
CJ will be confronted with at the end of
act 1 and the death of her brother it's
at school where we also get to know what
CJ's weaknesses as a character she's
stubborn rash and doesn't take input
from anyone else her whole conversation
with mr. Lockhart is about how she won't
accept her b-plus as an acceptable grade
in the next scene she flies off the
handle and attacks her ex-boyfriend
Jared later on Calvin tells her if she
would just listen more maybe she would
act right and finally her mom tells her
that she's just like her father stubborn
so we know her weakness stubbornness and
hopefully throughout the journey she'll
move toward her strength reasonableness
but we'll come back to this in a bit
with her acceptance to MIT hinging on
her performance at the science Expo
c.j and sebastian fixed their machines
and successfully traveled one full day
back in time making sure not to run into
their past selves if they ran into their
past selves their future selves would
then know they succeeded in going back
in time which would screw everything up
in the timeline confusing I know but
here we see CJ's stubborn and rash
behavior when she throws a slushy at her
ex effectively changing the sequence of
events and having Jared break his arm
when he's hit by a car after their 10
minutes are up CJ and Sebastian
transport back to present day where they
argue about the ethics of time-travel
sebastian argues that time-travel could
make things even worse but CJ
stubbornness is quick to put that idea
down it's only when Calvin dies a week
later that CJ uses her time machine to
stop his murder from happening the movie
does a good job at leaving the viewer in
the dark about what happened surrounding
Calvin's death we're told that he was
taking out his phone but the camera cuts
before we see the sequence of events
this is a deliberate choice made by the
filmmaker showing us how muddy these
situations can get when there are no
cameras around we have to rely on
eyewitness statements and those of the
officers something that has happened in
real life countless times and spurred
scorn from groups like black lives
matter
CJ devises a way to change the spin of
the electrons and create antimatter with
enough energy to travel two times the
speed of light this would allow them
theoretically to go up to a week back in
time and it works but Jared and his gang
stop them before they can reach Calvin
after a brief chase CJ hears the gunshot
in the distance and fails to save her
brother but not to fret they can try
again this time deciding to stop the
robbery at the bodega from happening the
robbery which started the sequence of
events which led to Calvin's death stop
the robbery stop the death but there is
a problem they now have two different
versions of themselves running around in
the past complicating things further in
order to solve this they'll need
Eduardo's quantum circuit boards which
contain enough energy to splice time
entirely effectively resetting their
previous jumps they travel back in time
and CJ immediately calls the police now
here's where things start to go downhill
upon noticing the cops
haven't arrived CJ's stubborn and rash
behavior compel her to go into the
bodega and notify the owner about the
robbers this completely backfires when
past Sebastian arrives and an
altercation between the robbers results
in him getting shot in turn this kills
future Sebastian since if he died in the
past he can no longer live in the future
in this new future Calvin has lived and
Sebastian has died to make matters worse
Sebastian's grandmother has gone to the
hospital suffering from a nervous
breakdown
CJ's decisions have only made things
worse with the help of Calvin and
Eduardo they devised a plan to have CJ
travel to the exact moment CJ and
Sebastian previously jumped in which she
would reset her past self but not
Sebastian's is everyone following my
head's about to explode the plan is to
tell Sebastian what happened then stomp
Calvin from getting shot and even when
she shows him the pamphlet of his own
funeral and the dog tags only Calvin has
dog tags he said she'd only get over his
dead body they're too late to stop the
cops
Sebastian is arrested and Calvin notices
the funeral pamphlet turns into
Sebastian's funeral he then decides to
sacrifice himself to save Sebastian we
also see him fade away in the present as
well in the present CJ tell Sebastian
the truth that he had died in the past
and she saved him but Sebastian's had
enough he tells her they can't do this
anymore
but CJ being the stubborn one locks him
out of the garage and goes in for one
last try as we watch her run down the
street then it just ends and here's my
main argument about this film
there's no act 3 there is no ending
we've spent this whole story watching as
CJ stubbornness and rash behavior has
led to even more problems in a normal
movie we would see one of two things
happen either CJ learns from her
behavior changes and saves the day or
she doesn't learn from her bad behavior
embraces it even more and the film would
and tragically with her not learning
anything from it but this film doesn't
have either the ending is open-ended did
she save him or did she fail it's up for
you to decide but my interpretation is
that she is doomed to repeat this
forever
first she hasn't learned anything as a
character she's the same old
stubborn CJ plus in all her jumps time
has always found a way to correct itself
so that someone dies leading me to
believe that no matter what she does
something bad will happen this
unfairness is echoed by Calvin in his
talk to CJ in which he states that no
one deserves this it's his way of saying
that sometimes life isn't fair and we
just have to deal with it now CJ had
learned from her past behavior and
showed that she was changing as a
character I'd interpreted this ending
differently and if that were the case
the filmmakers probably would have been
better off actually showing it to give
people that happy ending
overall I expected her to somehow save
her brother but with no ending we never
get that cathartic release it just made
me more frustrated and wanting to go
back in time to get my hour-and-a-half
back but what did you guys think of the
ending should it have continued on or do
you like this open ambiguity of it all I
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe I got more videos on the way
and follow me on Twitter at think story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much